[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
we're already here any pictures yeah I
saw that I would hope we will get talked
off by one I'm worried near though the
disciple because it
[Applause]
[Music]
you
creative people are getting a really
rough but they're not getting a break at
all and they're probably more creative
people doing non creative work in the
work force than the other way around oh
definitely definitely and you know the
thing is I don't want to paint too
dismal a picture about being creative
because one of the things that pays off
big for creative people is that they get
to be creative right there's great
aesthetic joy in that in depth and I've
been privileged because I've worked with
more creative people then then then
would fall to the law let's say of the
typical psychotherapists because people
often come and see me because they've
watched my videos online and they deal
with people who are interested in those
subjects tend to be creative and one of
the things I've really been struck by
first of all I've learned that for those
of you are interested in such things
that the reason Union psychology works
is because it works for creative people
doesn't work at all for non creative
people it's just false dead and flat for
them they're not interested in at all
isn't how they think you mean as therapy
yeah that it doesn't match it doesn't
match their personalities whereas
creative people man they dream
archetypal dreams all the time it's
really interesting and also they die if
they're if they're not being creative
they wither on the vine I had one client
I really liked him he was a brilliant
architect and his rational mind was his
worst enemy because it just criticized
everything he's hyper rational
criticized everything and really in a
dark way and effectively you know is if
I could get him to not think and just
create he was a complete genius he could
that's where all of the vitality in his
life was you know that's where the SAP
rose up inside the dead tree that was
sort of embedded inside of him and it is
very common with creative people is that
it's their lifeblood and it really is
from a biological perspective this is
some epiphenomena it's it's it's built
right into people and deeply
you